ارجع السوق هذا الاسبوع افضل بكثير من
الاسبوع الماضي لقد بلغ ذروته في الثانيه
عشر من الشهر الجاري عند مصطفى حوالي 240
الى 350 شخصا خارج المستشفى لتلقي العلاج
والان العدد يتراوح بين 240 و250 كان
الناس ينتظرون حوالي ثلاثا الى اربع ساعات
الان يستغرق الامر حوالي نصف ساعه
عكس بقيه العالم لا حديث في الصين الا عن
فيروس كورونا كمامات وفحوص المستشفيات تعج
بالمرضى والسلطات تحاول فرض رقابه على ما
ينشر عن الموضوع صور تذكر بايام بدايه
الجائحه
تقارير تتحدث عن 250 مليون اصابه في مختلف
في مناطق البلاد خلال 20 يوما فقط ما
يعادل 18 في المئه من السكان وفقا لتقدير
داخلي من كبار الصحه
على سبيل المثال تواجه المقاطعه الصناعيه
في الصين اصابات مرتفعه وصلت الى المليون
يوميا ومن المتوقع ان تتضاعفه وفقا حكومه
المقاطعه اعتقد ان الوضع في المستشفى جيد
بشكل عام من رائع ان نرى قسم الطوارئ يعمل
على هذا النحو من جهاتها توقعت حكومه
مقاطعه في منشور على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ان يصاب 80% من اين يمثل نحو 36
مليون شخص بالفيروس حتى مارس
الاحصاءات على صعيد البلاد غير مكتمله بعد
ما توقفت لجنه الصحه الوطنيه عن الابلاغ
عن اعداد الاصابات مما يجعل من الصعب تتبع
الحالات مجموعه عالميه تعمل على تتبع
انتشار فيروس كورونا قالت ان تفشل وباء في
الصين ياتي بسبب سلالات الفيروس التي
انتشرت في انحاء العالم مع عدم وجود
علامات حتى الان على ظهور متحولات جديده
خطيره
بلال الوجداني العربيه